first light over the Tyne another day of
this this thing that has changed
everything there's just a handful of
passengers who need to get across the
river
this is Chris's first day wearing the
visor it is pretty scary every day you
come to work and you hope and pray that
this is not the day I'm gonna catch
coronavirus you know he those two people
that have died in the past week and the
stuff you know others we're not coming
in we're all clean and everything like
you know what we want to keep ourselves
right you know what girl PPE and but the
you know the the banner for for one of a
better would that's not there a monster
stuff there you know carry a Moyo have
only really just started studying in the
Northeast now their parents are telling
them that be safer at home in Nigeria
than they are in Newcastle for a city
with so many friendly people went
something like this happens Heidi how
hard it is for them to I mean normally
you would be walking on the road I could
easily just wave to a stranger yeah
because a stranger for ask a stranger
for directions that they are so building
enthusiastic but now it's mentally
draining when you're walking on the road
and one person is working you don't know
which way I now cross to the other side
you know makes us not feel human to one
another I fix it with our humanity I
don't even get one saying it's a weird
feeling
we met Mick at the big market normally
home of the loud and Larry Newcastle
night out
the soldiers driving driving along the
streets and like Fame one bit I'm trying
to cheer scepter just so you pick
something all beers at me would be nice
to get back to normal if I'd be honest
with you and if that means that the big
mall have been an absolute mess and so
be it that's what we used to and then
you know this is the city's buzzin again
this is where it all started the first
kovat nineteen patients in the UK came
to this part of the city's Hospital on
the 31st of January for me it feels like
a year it's only been 3 months really
matthias received those first patients
and has helped lead their response to
what's followed I don't think we will be
able to eradicate this disease over the
next year or 2 years we have to live
with it so our Hospital is is making
plans to live with this for the next
year to two years and therefore
everybody else has to do that new cases
are still coming in but the numbers are
significantly down outside the lockdown
is starting to ease this is the point
when they need the public to help the
prospect that we might put ourselves in
a situation where we can't offer the
standard of care that we wish to and
that we train to is is horrifying to
everybody and and that's how important
it is that we don't do anything that
might risk a second surge is a little
bit worse than the first one then all
the good work we've undone you know
everything that we've sacrificed
everybody over the last few weeks will
be undone
Lisa was furloughed from her job as a
nursery teaching assistant this is her
new role this isn't being able to make
sure I've got an income but I'm able to
put food on the table for my daughter
and my partner otherwise I couldn't have
wouldn't have managed I think we'll have
to resort to sort the food banks and
born a family and friends and obviously
you can call your family and friends at
the minute because of the pandemics or
this is like massively made such a
difference to my life
[Music]
when you get home to your family how do
you describe what's happened to the city
I kind of Seir ask them if they've seen
the film 20th years later which is a
song people obey when nobody's in the
streets and stuff like that messy
imagine that without the zombies and
that's that's what kind of one is the
late shift on the Metro rattling around
an empty city where people can see the
pain that is coming down the line I have
lots of jobs and the recession I used to
work from Northern Rock many years ago
which is a huge Bank and look what
happened to that and we've all made
redundant through that and it's scary to
think that people other people are going
to go through that we're quite lucky
because the fastest way we're providing
an essential service now it's that I
think that's where a lot of the
frustrations are coming from not just in
the Northeast but right across the world
is because people are needing those
answers I'm not going to have a job
before bath - how am I going to feed my
family in six months and if I don't have
like job
and then there is the club the club that
delights distracts and deflates this
city yes the view enjoyed by the
hundreds of thousands of tons every year
it's up to be fantastic it's just an
absolute city of black and white yeah
and then the whole most of the city is
absolutely fantastic this should be last
orders time at the strawberry none of us
know really what's gonna come if we get
to open up in July or August it's their
limited numbers that will be allowed
into a pope to be fair you couldn't
really show up the live game on the TV
you could never ask in Newcastle United
fun to sit still and watch something and
not moved from his seat no its life is
changing they want their city back and
at some point it will return but none of
it will happen overnight
Tom Parmenter Sky News tyneside